a lighter who joins us right here from
the YES Network oh you you made mention
of this during your broadcast with Kay
and flower tea over the weekend I did
rich that was a beautiful setup and I
thought you were going to tell me that
after that inning we played five more
innings the Red Sox didn't have an
extra-base hit 16 innings at Fenway Park
in a red sock Yankee series are you
crazy it was incredible it was
absolutely incredible you know you know
what I did say that on the air because
we were dumbfounded was summoned through
like the rulebook we're trying to figure
it out we have a producer doing it there
call in New York it's like craziness
response inform the viewers and then we
assume that you know he didn't purposely
obstruct her or try to obstruct the play
my only guess is is that Matt Holliday
could have assumed or at least it was
assumed that the ball was a line drive
and he it was caught in the air and he
tagged first and it was going to be that
a run down that would be the only way
for an umpire to say that it didn't
deflect because you could see the way
that the play was made I mean Moreland
was like in a bad spot and you know it
got old it got ugly but but oh can you
can you as an umpire though I used to
tell John foul well Holliday could have
thought that there was a an out at first
base already recorded meaning he could
get back to four how is that even used
as an excuse you don't and I'm
embarrassed to tell you rich that I
still haven't heard the exact ruling
there right the exact thing that I I'm
with you I'm you do all the NFL stuff
like put the headset on tell everybody
in the stadium just what the ruling was
good bad or indifferent yeah and then
the number of times though that the
umpires review something and then point
to the base and say safe or out and
we're supposed to assume okay does that
mean you saw evidence to actually keep
the play standards as called or to not
review it what are we doing right to not
reverse it it seems to me it's just
simple to put a mic on the UMP and I've
never thought I would ever say I want to
hear from Joe West but you know let's
hear right I mean let's hear no that's
good rich you know what listen wit
baseball I say we we now have
plays you know that's only going to get
even more involved and they'll include
more place I was also intrigued and we I
think Michael K play my plan yes you
know there was some incidents where
there was a foul ball that was clearly
foul home run and you know it was late
in the game he already had used his his
replace instant replay calls and
cederstrom just kept allowing him to go
you know frivolously I thought so
you know something will happen i it's
very simple you have thirty forty
thousand however many people are in the
stands and everybody's kind of sitting
there wondering what the ruling is
outliner of the MLB Network joining me
here on the rich eyes and showing again
MLB Network is going to air live
baseball five out of seven days this
week including tonight's Indians Giants
game and you can watch Al tomorrow on
MLB central at 10:00 a.m. Eastern Time
he's joining me here on the show how
good are the Dodgers al what do you say
oh you know rich uh they're I mean
listen out of there to last twenty six I
think they're twenty three and three and
you know we know what Cody Bellinger is
done we certainly Kershaw Alex wood to
me is one of the more special stories in
the game a guy that was always a
talented lefty and you know whether he
got a fair share or not in Atlanta I
mean what he's done I mean it I think I
read a stat today he was the only Dodger
to go ten and oh I mean he ran under two
at the all-star break you know you throw
in the you know just III say retail and
you know the depth of what the Dodger
front offs had done the last few years
and not signing Greinke and having all
of these these different players that
can mix and match I think it'll be
interesting you know as to what they do
when Aegon assuming that Adrian Gonzalez
comes back because what a problem that
would be right you put Bellinger in the
outfield they only get stronger and now
rich I mean I'll bid it's a rumor but
they're talking possibly training for
Zach Britton as you imagine what that
would do to already have in Kenley
Jansen and shorten in the game yeah it's
basically like when when our aces plural
aren't on the mound try and beat us in
seven innings and then the Nationals
strengthen their bullpen over the
weekend by acquiring both Ryan Madson
and Sean Doolittle from the A's do you
think this puts the Nationals on equal
footing with the Dodgers a lot
think it makes them definitely more
intriguing but interestingly enough rich
you know neither one of those guys were
the closer for the A's respectively with
with Casias closing and I just think you
look at what now the Nationals have and
trading away a nice young talented
sinker ball hard sinker ball guy and
Blake treinen you I just I don't know
what Dusty Baker does you tell me if
this is going to be a lefty righty
tandem of Madson Doolittle and they were
closers before injuries etc you can't
have I don't think you have to know the
solidified aspect of who's pitching when
and I can't stand what I hear variety
arias people that that haven't sat in
the bullpen or don't think that it
really matters much as to where you
bring a guy in if he's your closer and
the high-leverage inning is in the
seventh inning bring them in the seventh
inning it's not it's not your your vibe
as a human as you sit out there and you
play out the game I think I don't know
but I think if the Nationals they
Meister not finished because that was
their biggest flaw or wart on their team
was their bullpen and it definitely got
a lot better but I just don't know who
would be the closer and I can't imagine
dusty having to do like a lefty righty
closer tandem well I think you asked any
national fan right now and they're like
that what this is is better than the
decision that ústí how to make 24 hours
ago because it was anybody bought
anybody that was coming out of the pen
if you look at it Washington's 19 games
over 500 out I mean they had six losses
when leading after eight innings this
year that said that's a very
disheartening as you know and anybody
who's a baseball fan you come into a
game and we saw it in my series up in
New York up in Boston you know with
Chapman walking in the winning run and
then Kimbrel who hadn't blown a save in
Boston gives up a solo home run in the
ninth and that 16 inning eventual win by
the Yankee so those are absolutely
heartbreaking losses and the Nationals
that you decided having multiple losses
when your team is up trying to finish
out a game I just I'm not sure I'm not
sure where you go I'm in Madison the
last time he he really you know it was 2
years ago we've 30 saves this year I
said you know
hasn't been the closure and I love
Doolittle's arm and there's no denying
that they both have closer stuff you're
right
they are marketed li improved today than
they were a couple days ago allied or a
couple more minutes here with the allied
or the MLB network here in the Rich
Eisen show meanwhile the Cubs come out
and sweep the Baltimore Orioles to start
the second half of the season and then
get a gem from Jose Quintana and his
first start as a Chicago cub do you
believe that this team has turned a
corner now I think by based on what
cantana did yesterday against the
Orioles I mean he was dominating the 12
strikeouts impressive I think everybody
scout evaluators baseball evaluators
watching cantana he's under control it
was a no brainer I love it I love it on
both sides I think recon has done an
unbelievable job accumulating prospects
over the last year now with with the
sale trade and Adam Eaton and now in
this trade with Quintana and also I get
it for the Cubs you got younger you have
you have cantana under control he's an
all-star he was last year I know he's
struggled a bit I think it's a lot of it
has been mental rich when you have a
young pitcher like this who's under
control for a few more years and you're
hearing at a spring training that you
may get traded it has affected him more
so mentally I think his stuff is
terrific and it's only only helped the
Cubs who obviously they have to get back
to close to what they they were last
year when in the world see how do you
think they've turned a corner
I got mean I didn't hear a yes so you
think maybe they have not we still need
to see more I think when you when you
obtain a talented young arm like that
yes I just seen them flounder at 500 up
to this point of you know over 90 games
into this season you know they're better
than that and you know III don't know if
just content is the guy that's going to
make them now 15 games over 500 team but
they have to play played it better than
they've that they have so what do you
think about the Astros in the American
League because we're talking about
Washington maybe the Cubs catch fire the
Dodgers or who they are the Diamondbacks
have been playing excellent baseball in
the American League as you saw you saw
just a the Yankees and the Red Sox two
teams that I think have some hole
and then you got Cleveland that's trying
to get its footing like the Cubs and
then Houston that's destroying everybody
I got George Springer on an hour three
what do you think of the Astros oh my
god the most explosive offense up
certainly in the American League you
know I when you look at all of the
metrics of this team rich I mean just
absolutely impressive my issue is going
to be and it always comes down to that
who's going to be your 1 2 3 you know
you know I know Keiko has been on the DL
recently but you got McCullers I like I
like Morton I liked fires I like the
guys and they certainly run away with it
their bullpen absolutely solidified with
Ken Giles precious and divinsky their
offense is so talented and young and
exciting explosive they need another
starter period and if they do that now
when you match up with either the
national or if you match up with what
looks like the Red Sox will eventually
be taking off I was already getting them
in the world seriously that and yet the
assumption is that the Indians will
figure it out I really like them as we
solved or was it five years ago when si
had them as yeah that's right you know
the World Series which is pretty
impressive if that comes true
now you're the serial man you and K and
Flaherty this weekend we're terrific I
love listening to you guys you grow
that's right that's nice here it's
you're terrific as well thanks buddy the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy